se hace una función doblemente
diferenciable
definida sobre el intervalo cerrado
menos 77 así que incluye a los extremos
del intervalo
a continuación se muestra la gráfica de
la segunda derivada de 'heavy prima así
que estas las gráficas de hacer una
derivada y justo aquí nos lo dicen
esta es la gráfica de james igual a g be
prima de x y nos preguntan cuántos
puntos de inflexión tiene la gráfica de
la función g bueno primero vamos a
recordar que es un punto de inflexión un
punto de inflexión es donde pasamos de
una concavidad hacia abajo a una
concavidad hacia arriba algo como esto u
otra forma de verlo es donde la
pendiente de mi recta tangente pasa de
decrecer a crecer como por ejemplo aquí
esta es la pendiente de mi recta
tangente y va cambiando aquí es menor
aquí es menor
aquí es menor aquí es menor y de repente
empieza a crecer de nuevo tenemos una
pendiente mayor o una mayor una mayor
así que aquí tenemos un punto de
inflexión para algún valor de x donde
esto pase
o viceversa puedes ir en la otra
dirección puedes tener una función que
se vea así donde tenemos una pendiente
negativa pero nuestra pendiente empieza
a crecer y a crecer y a crecer ya crecer
y de repente nuestra pendiente empieza a
decrecer de nuevo así que aquí tenemos
otro punto de inflexión es decir otro
valor para x donde esto sucede bueno en
otros vídeos vamos a trabajar más con la
inclusión de cómo se comporta la primera
y la segunda derivada en un punto de
inflexión pero en esta gráfica de aquí
que nos da el ejercicio lo que nos piden
es que encontremos los puntos de
inflexión cuando nos dan la segunda
derivada y eso es igual a preguntarnos
en donde la función de la segunda
derivada cruza el eje x
no es suficiente que toquemos el eje x
lo que necesitamos es cruzar el eje x
así que justo aquí cruzamos el eje x
perfecto allí tenemos un punto de
inflexión porque también cruzamos el eje
x así que de nuevo tenemos otro punto de
inflexión de observar aquí tocamos el
eje x es decir nuestra segunda derivada
es igual a 0 pero no cruzamos el eje x
es decir no pasamos de tomar valores
positivos a valores negativos y
simplemente nos quedamos con valores
positivos de igual manera por acá tal
vez algo interesante pase después de
este punto pero ojo solo nos dicen que
esta función está definida en este
intervalo así que de hecho es lo que
pasa después de este punto ya no nos
interesa y por lo tanto no vamos a
cruzar el eje x entonces la respuesta a
cuántos puntos de inflexión tenemos en
nuestra gráfica bueno es simplemente 2
observando la gráfica de la segunda
derivada por aquí ahora bien ya que
sabemos la respuesta seguramente te
preguntarás por qué esto tiene sentido
porque tenemos que cruzar el eje x bueno
simplemente imaginemos lo siguiente
imaginemos que aquí tenemos la gráfica
de la segunda derivada así que esta es
mi prima ok entonces la gráfica de la
primera derivada se podría ver más o
menos así la primera derivada se podría
ver así donde aquí tenemos una pendiente
negativa menos negativa menos negativa y
después se hacer que se acerca una
pendiente de cero y de repente la
pendiente se convierte en positiva y
empieza a crecer así que ésta sería efe
prima de x y ahora podrías pensar que si
esto describe la derivada de nuestra
función entonces cómo se vería nuestra
función bueno nuestra función por aquí
tendría una pendiente muy positiva pero
la pendiente se mantendría decreciendo
decreciendo hasta llegar a este punto de
aquí y después crecería de nuevo así que
por ejemplo la función se vería algo así
tengo una pendiente muy positiva
después empieza a decrecer a decrecer a
decrecer y después por aquí la pendiente
empieza a crecer de nuevo
así que por aquí tenemos una pendiente
positiva que empieza a decrecer observa
ene efe prima es lo que nos está
diciendo la pendiente positiva está
decreciendo y luego pasamos a tener una
pendiente que sigue siendo positiva pero
que ahora empieza a crecer de nuevo
espero que esto te dé la razón del por
qué es necesario cruzar el eje x en
nuestra segunda derivada muy bien hasta
aquí este vídeo nos vemos en el
siguiente